Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Today we're going to talk about an algorithm
that is capable of filling holes in space
and time.
Classical image inpainting, or in other words,
filling holes in images is something that
we've explored in earlier episodes - there
are several incredible techniques to take
care of that.
But with this piece of work, it is possible
to generalize such a technique for video,
and fill holes for not only one image, but
a series of images.
Like removing a umbrella to create an unoccluded
view to the beach.
Or removing a waving person from a video of
us jogging.
These results are truly incredible, and even
though this method was published long long
ago, it still enjoys a great deal of reverence
among computer graphics practitioners.
Not only that, but this algorithm also serves
the basis of the awesome content aware fill
feature introduced in Adobe Photoshop CS5.
In this problem formulation, we have to make
sure that our solution has spatio-temporal
consistency.
What does this mean exactly?
This means that holes can exist through space
and time, so multiple frames of a video may
be missing, or there may be regions that we
wish to cut out not only for one image, but
for the entirety of the video.
The filled in regions have to be consistent
with their surroundings if they are looked
at as an image, but there also has to be a
consistency across the time domain, otherwise
we would see a disturbing flickering effect
in the results.
It is a really challenging problem indeed
because there are more constraints that we
have to adhere to, however, a key observation
is that it is also easier because in return,
we have access to more information that comes
from the previous and the next frames in the
video.
For instance, here, you can see an example
of retouching old footage by removing a huge
pesky artifact.
And clearly, we know the fact that Charlie
Chaplin is supposed to be in the middle of
the image only because we have this information
from the previous and next frames.
All this is achieved by an optimization algorithm
that takes into consideration that consistency
has to be enforced through the spatial and
the time domain at the same time.
It can also be used to fill in completely
missing frames of a video.
Or, it also helps where we have parts of an
image missing after being removed by an image
stabilizer algorithm.
Video editors do this all the time, so such
a restoration technique is super useful.
The source code of this technique is available,
I've put a link to it in the video description.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!